hello everyone and welcome back to game
review
my name is Keith Denby and today I
wanted to go over yet another game from
the chest bolt Masters Tournament this
one was played between Dan'l dubov and
magnus carlsen and these are two players
that have kind of surprisingly developed
a little bit of a friendly rivalry as of
late
dubov is a very young Russian
Grandmaster kind of he broke into the
top echelon of these players a little
bit ago and in this new age of online
tournaments he's got a very good
reputation as an excellent rapid chess
player and he's been sort of taking down
some of the big names he's got a couple
really nice wins against Magnus Carl's
Magnus Carlsen in these past few
tournaments he's played in and this game
unfortunately for dubov was not a story
of that it was a story of Magnus Carlsen
taking his revenge on the Russian
youngster in this game let's jump into
it here we had dubov with white playing
the move in d4 Knight f6 by Magnus
Knight f3 by dubov we have d5 c4 c6
Knight c3 and now the movie 6 and Magnus
chooses the semi Slav or as I like to
call it the big triangle defense you
build a triangle towards the center
supporting your d5 pawn with all you've
got and Black's idea in this opening is
sort of sometimes you do see black
capturing this pawn on c4 but the the
truth theme of the triangle is you build
this pawn up on d5 and you hold it there
forever and ever ever and you just claim
you're never going to beat me on these
light squares and that's exactly what
Magnus goes for in this game it's a very
valid plan to go for it we have g3 by
dubov and now he's transposing more into
some Catalan type positions it is
totally possible to play move like III
play move like Bishop c5 and go for more
standard qgd setups but instead we have
g3 going for the Catalan a knight be g7
by the world champion Bishop g2 Bishop
e7 castles and castles and now black is
sort of misses
chance to take on c4 if that was what he
was going to do he could have done so
here he could have even done so in this
exact position as well but instead
castles castles and now white sort of
takes this option away from black by
playing the move b3 d takes c4 is just
never gonna be the same because white
captures immediately towards the center
with upon controlling the d5 square even
more so note take some c4 this game
instead the main move by the world
champion is b6 and now dubov made an
interesting decision here to play the
move rook e1 and this is a very much
non-standard move in this position it
looks very very you know sort of normal
you play rook e1 is 44 but after delving
into these lines a little bit and turns
out Bishop b2 is by far the main move
Bishop a 6 is sort of the main reply it
by black threatening this pawn white
deals with this threat by playing the
move Knight d2
black quite often plays the move rook c8
to support the center and now if dubov
played the movie rook e1 in this
position or if white played the move
rook e1 in this position we would sort
of transpose to this game between dubov
and Carlsen but instead in this exact
position white has this additional
option of playing the movie 4 and I
think this is sort of a slightly more
respected mine for white in order to
play for a slight edge here just playing
efore this is normal
Catalan stuff now you break down the
light squares trying to activate this
Bishop on the long diagonal now we can
compare this position with what dubov
got in the game in the game he plays
rook e1 we see Bishop a6 by Magnus 92
all the same stuff rook c8 and Bishop b2
and now unfortunately dubov has sort of
missed the boat as far as playing e4
he's just a tempo too slow because he
included rook e1 now this was likely by
design for dubov I'm sure he was aware
of this efore option and just chose to
go for this instead but I don't think it
was a great decision because the
position that he got in the game was
honestly pretty uncomfortable for white
this allows Magnus to immediately break
with the move c5 this was the point of
rook c8 trying to put more
sure on c4 after move like C takes t4 in
D takes d4 due to this pressure
dubov chose to take on c5 we see Knight
takes e5 by black b takes d5 is not
going to be the most standard move
because I think in this case this is not
going to be a structure you're quite
happy with as suddenly this bishop is
going to be quite useful here attacking
these this hanging pawn structure as
it's known instead though Knight takes
d5 and now dubov goes for a pretty
interesting line with the move B 4 and
this invites a pretty drastic change in
structure if black were to just simply
retreat with a move like 97 this would
of course be devastating after the move
C takes d5 so Magnus is forced to sort
of go for this move Knight C to e4 and
now dubov captures on e4 we see D takes
e4 and this is now the change in
structure that we have achieved and do
bombs claim with this structure is
probably multi fold here just like the
paper tells he's attacking this pawn on
e4 he's gonna try to claim that this is
more of a weakness and then a benefit
for the world champion it's true that it
gives white or gives black quite a lot
of space but it is sort of overextended
and can be is susceptible to attack he's
also going to claim that in any endgame
he might achieve he does have a three
versus two majority on the Queen side
and the ability to create a passed pawn
sort of at a moment's notice with the
move c5 now the issue for dubov is that
all these claims might be valid in in
normal positions in this specific
position it looks as though black simply
has way too much activity to kind of
counteract these structural deficiencies
that white is claiming the black hats so
for the moment black is immediately
threatening to capture on b4 now white
would love to play the move a3 defending
this b4 pawn but this does allow the
very nice move III by black and this is
just going to be a devastating attack on
the white structure you know F takes e
all of
sudden this pond Falls as well and just
as an example line here obviously these
might not be the best moves for either
side but in any position now it's just
going to be black with the advantage
with these horrible fractured ponds in
the white camp so because of that this
leaves white with the only move here b5
sort of resolving both the problem b4
and c4 and III by saving these pawns
with tempo on the bishop but now Bishop
e7 this pawn is very adequately defended
and black sort of has no real issues
here III has to be played by dubov in
order to prevent this pawn from coming
forward but now of course Bishop b4 by
the world champion is putting a ton of
pressure on these white pieces rookie 2
is sort of the only move to unpin but
now Queen d3 and this is just a monster
position for the world champion if you
ask the computer it says that this
position is actually just equal to zero
zero zero
but obviously here any practical player
would I think takes the black pieces you
know there's so much work to be done in
an effort to untangle with this stupid
looking knight on the D 2 square and in
this game dubov was simply not up to the
task
rook b1 played in the game eyeing this
b4 bishop indirectly simply bishop c3
via the world champion now and
unfortunately for dubov he did have to
capture this bishop the game might have
continued Queen takes c3 gonna start
coming over to see one now to defend the
e4 pawn a little bit more Queen back to
d3 and it's still going to be massively
uncomfortable for dubov with all these
active pieces but at least these bishops
come off the board this Knights a little
bit more free to move about the cabin so
to speak in the game would in fact
continue here but instead dubov goes for
Bishop a3 and now the very very natural
move by Magnus work F to d8 is just
devastating for the way position with
this Knight once again coming under
under fire here on the D file Rick to b3
was due Bob's idea but now due to this
pin on the
Queen takes c4 is simply available to
Magnus Queen e1 steps out of one pin
steps into another pin unfortunately and
now simply Queen d5 puts more pressure
on this guy and now this should be for
was due Bob's only try to defend this
night and now sort of any move wins here
for Magnus you can simply take on b4 but
if you want to find the quote-unquote
brilliancy that Magnus played in the
game at home go ahead pause your videos
here the move of course that Magnus
played is Queen takes b3 just removing
this rook from the board and sacrificing
the Queen for a just overwhelming
position a takes b3 bishop takes before
is of course the point and so now Magnus
has a rook and a bishop in exchange for
the Queen and more than that in this
night on d2 it's just a huge issue for
white and it's one that's not going to
be solved very easily bishop f1 was due
Bob's choice and now the world champion
begins torturing his opponent by playing
the move a5 of course
a5 introduces no new threats to the
position but it highlights the fact that
there's simply just literally nothing
white can do to escape from this bind on
his position this Bishop has a choice
between three squares they can shuffle
back and forth the screen can go to d1
and back to back to e1 this rook can't
really legally move at the moment this
night of course can't move without
hanging the Queen and that's all the
pieces that that white has he has
nothing better to do than shuffle back
and forth just literally no way to
improve White's position here so a5 for
the world champion now Queen D 1 and
then Magnus of course plays the nice
move h6 once again highlighting that
there are zero useful moves for dubov in
this position and at this point dubov
had sort of seen enough and resigned in
this position after the move h6 forcing
resignation so a great game by Magnus
Carlsen showing dubov that he can score
some nice wins as well really crazy
stuff in the stressful masters
tournament I'm having a great
time analyzing these games and watching
these games live if you haven't been
checking out the tournament I would
highly encourage you guys to check it
out they've got a great commentary team
over there with our own yes or Sara Juan
providing some helpful commentary
alongside Petersfield they're really fun
stuff in the meantime though my name is
Caleb Denby thank you so much for
joining me on this episode of game
review and I will see you next time